Brian dlan helped out by Justin Schultz who's back
in the lineup tonight replacing rer
Evans ainson shot blocker down by Joey
dor pin stun to the outside mccan great
pass Larson a shot picked off by Carter
Hart Philadelphia second in the Metro division
Jordan Everly up top Brian Duman risting one
pad save Hart Tatar moves it along and now
Frost out to Center Ice Morgan Frost hits
the line ainson a shot easy detection for
Joey deor Alex wenberg game-winning goal in
Calgary on Wednesday this is Jared mccan
Brandon tanip slapping one kicked out by
Hart the rebound and it comes out to Center
I caught him in a bad spot in that leg left
Everly drags it shoots it just high and off
the shoulder shoulder of Carter Hart cover
the front and the knees look out look out
the C with a stop Mercy what a save on Sha
cerer good on you 35 lonis on
cier supported by our great crew good stick there
by sealer shut down the plate Ryan paling goes
wide a shot caught by Joey dor that was not an
easy save there because their penalty killing
is great exactly now kekney sends it back oh and
tipping a chip off the crossbar by Morgan Frost
weak side watch right in front of the net there's
the tip and Johnny great pick up by you right off
the flush off the crossbar wow well a good play
just to keep that pu rebound Brinks on it Bobby
Brink gal by forer and now zamula cross eyes Brink
on the march with a shot caught by dord sweat
jackets or sweat suits it's a nice look it sure
is warm zamula tipped far tried to bank it in no
dice on the weak side Steeler's made a couple of
really good plays in this game so far Dort kicks
it out right to Garnet Hathaway who stumbles a
bit takes a swap got it done who survives it and
he'll get it back from Jordan Everly H Dunn Four
Points in his last two games Seattle's leading
scorer Andre burkovski navigates through the
middle goes wide all the way across Ken got to
start shooting the puck here there's some angles
to get the puck to net or opportunities to get
the puck to the net they have two shots Seattle
Duman chipped wide Yamoto put it in between Hart
and the a wide open net Breakaway Joel fary mono
Mano stopped by Joey dor far held in front over
skated by Bobby Brink well here comes the breakway
for far and nice job here by Joey dor as he goes
down he keeps that paddle along nice and get a
good look right here attemps to try to go five
ho Spokan native drops it off here comes Alexia
the Joey chance short side held by Under some
pressure borgan now Everly maty baners gains the
zone to the slot toar stopped by Hart attacking
save by Carter Hart give Carter Hart some credit
here's a great play by Maddie great job by es to
drive the net creates the chance and look at
hard comes right out on top of the blue paint
and look at Tatar stick ready no stick handle
lets it go right to seal it on lton they go to
the corner Everly is pushed by sanheim Tatar
with it onetime Schultz caught by Carter Hart
below the line wenberg over here for Jared mccan
steered in by Dunn picked off a breakout lton
with Travis connect KN lton drags it off a stick
conne in tight they score pinballs off Vince done
their top goal getter Travis kekney will pick
up Philadelphia's ninth short-handed goal the
season he's defensively marked by dlan then tanov
they go to the Wall Brandon tanv not out settled
tip it a shot sealed off by dor collected by
wber good poke check by cam yor it comes out
to Center paling now goes wide shoots it blocker
Sav to cord Walker Bobby Frink zings a pass and
back of bar who's got it he'll cycle out sealer
swallowed up by Joey DOR getting ready for way
to break in the National Hockey League season
in 2024 the Winter Classic dord will shut the
door on that Schultz for Seattle gour out of
the corner Oliver borran a short side bid good
idea there done in deep bers to the slot a shot
T her says no loose at the side of the goal and
off the scramble it's Frozen back in the first
period watch the left side of the net what a
stop by heart the Flyers with a one- nothing lead
here in the second period good play wiberg's got
the puck he inted through Center great shift
by wber he's in shorthanded stopped by Carter
har the Flyers change now off the icing Larson
mccan will chip it in Tai cier moves the puck
Kyler Yamamoto dun out in front tipped High
Kier it hit the crossbar and somehow the puck
ends up getting deflected and there's that
redirect right off the bar Johnny as you
mentioned by Ty Kier what a play by Dunner
and then M there's definitely that onetime
option available but I also think mccan did
not place that exactly where he wanted kind
of hit Carter heart in the middle a lot of
times you see him pick a spot getting it to
the left to the right side on the outside done
scores Shooters mentality you heard it just a
few seconds ago power play goal vinston Seattle
has tied it as well as anybody on this roster
and there he goes look at the net front presence
look at yamamoto's there wiberg's there Steeler
is there look at this wall right here right
there I mean almost impossible ible for the
goenda puck good things happen JT and maybe
that goes off a sealer but you know what hey
they don't ask how look out Morgan pressured by
haway here's Bor strand in a one all standoff
great pass mcan's in power move stopped great
save some rough stuff after this great stop
by Carter har Stick Around by Adam Larson
that's the whole concept of a body check
to separate the player gour denied by har
he centers one across with Gordon Schultz
yorran will dangle the Maestro shot denied
by har there was some room on that short
Side High some tired guys out there right now
for Philly see if the Kraken can capitalize
Bor strand downstairs they score hey hey what
do you say Justin shuls and the Kraken win in
overtime left part of your screen
Ali finds Justin Schulz right over
the left pad of Carter Hart and let's
not forget again oh excuse me that goes
between the legs I thought it
went over the pad it goes five
gole but let's not forget again the
huge defensive play by Vince dun